there's plenty of a superb anecdotes
about the history of the buys and and so
on
I suppose the earlier question which if
we want to go right back to Ground Zero
who invented the word and beat a chap at
guess where Bell Labs
jong-kook II worked with Shannon and
others a bit I think it was here in a
paper in 1947 actually uttered the word
bit rather than binary digit for the
first time so how big should your
groupings of bits be to hold the numbers
you were interested in and this is the
key to it all early computers were word
based later on the idea of the byte came
to be not synonymous but associated with
what's the amount of storage we'd have
to set aside for holding a character but
you know real programmers aren't
bothered with wofully bits of text what
numbers you know the obsession with the
early computer pioneers was very much
we're gonna build these things because
they're interesting in their own right
electronic general-purpose computers but
what we really want to do is about to do
serious applied mathematics engineering
quantum chemistry computer science x-ray
crystallography radio astronomy all good
solid scientific things which need
guaranteed decimal accuracy so
remembering the rule of three point
three to two which I don't have on my
teacher this time sorry about that
and if anybody wants to produce a
teacher without on by 13.3 to to is the
multiplying factor how much more binary
circuitry you need in your arithmetic
unit of your computer to be able to do
things in binary arithmetic rather than
decimal arithmetic the lodging bits the
computer it's a no-brainer it's yes no
decision so proper binaries find there
but why not use decimal integers well
using decimal in two
we can point to the previous video on
this it's fine but you've got to stay
below ten different voltages for ten
different levels of decimal digit you've
only got to to stabilise for binary it's
much simpler to build in binary but you
have to accept you will need three point
three three whatever times the amount of
binary components to do arithmetic then
you wouldn't be decimal okay so that's
accepted that we build in binary
but for school use you were taught how
to use logs to do your multiplies with
four decimal digits of accuracy Babbage
and others wanted at least 10 digit in
fact I've not got them here at home
they're gonna work I've actually got 10
digit long tables quite a big thick book
of them so if 10 digits was deemed to be
a pretty decent starting point multiply
by 3 points 3 2 2 and you can see by the
time you got to something like 33 36 bit
for safety maybe groupings you're
beginning to get the 10 decimal digits
of accuracy that you want so you look at
EDSAC a first generation computer which
we've been talking about net sacks only
got an 18-bit word of which 17 bits are
useful but by the time only gloom two of
those together in some way you're up to
35 36 bits now you're talking that's
getting as the accuracy with one however
at greater expense of course
contemporaneously as we now know with
age so it was the edvac they went for 40
bits straight away so they didn't have
to double up the locations more
expensive to build of course but 40 bits
fine that will get you 10 or 12 possibly
decimal digits even when I came to do my
work early work on quantum chemistry all
along you were aware of not wanting to
lose precision on your decimal digit
calculations and take great care about
rounding errors and stuff like this I
once looked at some examples for the
Cambridge diploma because for many years
from about the early fifties onwards
Cambridge did a post graduate diploma in
computing yeah based around the EDSAC
you went there a lot of
famous computer scientists converting
themselves if you like by doing the
Cabbage Diploma awful lot of those
diploma papers were numerical analysis
there was the odd question in there
which was shock horrid non-numerical
covering things like algorithms for the
Traveling Salesman problem but then the
next question would be you know how
could you invert a household a normal
matrix of dimension twenty by twenty in
the minimal number of operations without
losing decimal precision in the fifths
decimal point all this kind of stuff
that was the background
scientists mathematicians and engineers
built computers and they built them to
do hardcore numeric calculations so was
that all there was to it
no on the sidelines and treated quite
honestly and shamefacedly I say this in
many ways with a bit of division was
commercial computing and the company as
I'm sure you all know that was
instrumental in leading the way with
that was IBM IBM for years and years and
years was the biggest computer company
in the world it's probably in probably
still in the top ten but I'm guessing
that Microsoft Apple and Google will be
bigger than IBM in terms of revenues
nowadays yeah IBM of course had got the
best part of almost a cent now half a
century a good half a century of lead in
using punched cards as a means of
holding data and even though the
machinery that sorted them collated them
and could even do elementary additions
and subtractions of the codes that were
on the task IBM was the market leader by
a mile
others tried to get in on the act and
get a little bitty action and they did
but the industry leader was Ibn so Jaime
em understood about real data okay then
so they were the right people to
basically start saying you look at these
computers now and how they handle
characters it's pathetic
and it is because you can go back to our
edsac
video about how to bring hi but it
doesn't matter whether printing out hi
or hello world you look at the way that
these early computers did characters and
it was absolutely suboptimal
the story was well if you don't want to
fill up your word with lots and lots of
bits the real scientists use you could
always fill up a subset of your work
with maybe five bit for a bordo code or
invent your own 6-bit code to stop
having to use finger shift a letter
shift turn it from third to
possibilities to 64 so five six bit
characters were common but some people
started to say well you always go on
about memory being so massively
expensive and so precious and yet on
EDSAC you're saying well it's five bit
character so you can economize can you
by squeezing three five bit characters
into a seventeen bit word no why would
you do that it's to be hell to get them
out again you'd have to do bit shifts
and all sorts you to slow things down so
when you look on an early machine like
it suck it uses five bit characters in
the middle of an 18-bit word and the
rest of the 13 bits just don't do
anything
IBM came along and said look here's the
story for those of you got lots of money
and don't matter spending it we have the
perfect solution stop making the word be
your minimum addressable unit address
the characters inside it individually
and in order to keep things clean and to
allow for future expansion don't mess
about with multiples of two like six bit
characters let's be brave and so write
8-bit characters now a long for a while
before all this came about people had
been calling groups of bits of arbitrary
size five bits six bits been calling
them bytes but IBM proposed to
standardize on the word byte being an
8-bit entity and here's the win-win
situation for those of you mad
mathematicians and engineers we can
arrange the hardware to regrow regard
groups of four of those as being a
32-bit word it's a win-win
IBM can dominate not only commercial
computing but can also make a reasonably
good showing because of the sheer speed
of their hardware
a great expense in scientific computing
as well so people say oh great idea
oh wow yes that is you know now that
we've all got more money I can afford
more expensive things that is a sensible
way to do it without a doubt so the idea
was absolutely spot-on
you choose a byte width which is a power
of two and then you arrange to be able
to put together groupings of bytes that
form something sensible and bigger for
macho types who want to do real number
arithmetic so everything the garden is
lovely you've got 32 bits you've got 8
bits
it was almost end of story but not quite
because although IBM did very nicely
with things like the 370 one-nine-five
and so on at being a pretty good
mainstream scientific computer they
didn't really go for chasing the market
at the very top end because they just
wasn't enough in it for them they made
mega bucks of their commercial database
customers so right at the top end you
get alternative solutions emerging which
are still with us today started off with
a company called CDC and the brilliant
hardware engineer called Seymour Cray
and ears will say cray he left CDC
eventually yeah he did inform Cray
computers so yes at the supercomputer
end of things there was an alternative
market but IBM solidly there in the
middle said we do commercial and we do
scientific we rule the world and I think
they were remarkably prescient and they
even at the other end for soy's and
tried to get it right but failed but
maybe this will have to be another video
because it does complete the story is
what about people who wanted something
even cheaper than a 16-bit PDP lumen
wanted an 8-bit micro IBM saw that
coming and tried to get in there and
dominate it but for reasons we half
understand but can be revealed if
there's enough demand they did lose
control of that one particular piece of
data you have to wait for it to come
round again so that tape that you see
there is going at 5,000 the characters
per second yep
5,000 characters per second roughly I
think coverage comes to 30 miles an hour